uh for you this song has gone so crazy
so viral it's
obviously uh I saw you originally had
recorded it on your iPhone which is
crazy like the first first early version
right what is the app on an iPhone you
use is a garage band band lab band lab
band lab so what this the m is you just
do it into the phone mm- you I mean you
can if you like airpods which you can
use your airpod mics and then it records
the vocals so look if you have airpods
you record at the bottom at the phone if
you have the wires like apple wires you
put them in like that's what I did a mic
on you hold it in front of at what point
in time did you go back and re-record it
so it didn't sound like it was recorded
on a phone I never did they just mix my
vocals so the vocals we hear right now
are the OG iPhone vocals yeah besides
the clean version I re-recorded the
clean version but on my phone again
really so I didn't record so in studio
at all that's so crazy wow no excuses
man no no I I think I didn't start
getting into the studio until like now
like yesterday yeah so you just had the
crib just running save time that is so
crazy I don't have to wait on the
engineer like send my vocals just send
your vocals hey that's impressive man
kudos to you thanks um do you like uh
well first of all there's there's a few
like what has been the one VI cuz a lot
of people have made videos to your song
yeah
it seems to be the it like dance that
people are doing what has been the most
surreal moment you've had with this
record where you've seen
somebody post about it or dance to it or
acknowledge it obviously the remix is
[__] huge you got blue face and blue
bucks on it and mustard and all that but
in terms of just like people who have
like posted it like what has been a
surreal moment for you just coming from
being a 17y old CJ Stroud CJ Stroud like
when I saw him like hitting the dance or
like the squabble that's not my dance
but the squabble and then people put my
song behind it it was like wow was this
last week when he threw for 470 yards
broke this is like the first couple
weeks Bing oh no Rookie of the Year
Rookie of the Year for it doesn't even I
think to bet on it it's like minus 500
if you bet like he's he's murdering it
you a football fan M Ricky of the Year
me and TJ St both Ricky of the years you
might be right there uh I mean I gotta
keep working but you know what I'm
saying 100% uh what's your football team
Rams m h
what yeah so how youve been a Rams fan
for like three years what's your team
I'm Arizona Cardinal fan have you guys I
don't think you guys are well you guys
went to the Super Bowl in 09 but listen
well Larry Fitz yeah it takes real it
takes real uh intestinal fortitude to be
a fan of the Arizona Cardinal Rams as
well nah y'all just won a Super Bowl two
years ago when did you start becoming a
fan
2017 so what do you know two two three
years of of mediocrity even then with
Jared G y'all were decent who who I mean
was your team before then there was no
team in La so I didn't have a team I
like players so you're a player guy
who's your favorite football player ever
um I don't know you don't know CJ Stout
there you go Aaron
Donald puka you know about Puka Puka is
nice he's on my fantasy team he is he's
a baller how much money did you put in
uh our League's I think uh the winner
wins $2,400 so it's like $200 per buying
we got 12 teams nothing crazy but it's
very competitive it's a bunch of people
who take is crazy we we take it too
serious $200 is crazy yeah I mean it's
you play Fantasy
Football have you ever played fantasy
football do you know what that is yeah
you've never played is that like a age
thing you're trying to say like cuz I'm
young I don't know dude have you played
fantasy yes for free ESPN fantasy yeah
that's what I do but we put money up so
you set your lineup and you know it's
fun let's play next year when I turn 18
let's do it you could play as a kid no
but like when I turn 18 so then it's
like a thing oh he's 18 now he can play
with us oh that's fair do you guys do
draft nights yeah you guys get drunk and
do draft nights there's some drinking
and some weed for sure do you feel like
the weed like enhances like your
pics probably not like you see the
future no I feel like what I do is like
when I'm like trying to like cram and
study before a draft I feel like I
overthink it and then I end up like like
watching a podcast or something that
convinces me to take somebody I
shouldn't have take and then that this
year that didn't happen but this year
I'm actually rolling in fantasy pretty
well but I enjoy fantasy it's very
stressing it is stressful I mean but
realistically I always forget I think
that's why when you put money in you
make sure when it's free you like forget
yeah when you when it's free you forget
especially if it's just for like shits
and giggles but I do fantasy basketball
too you said [__] and what shits and
giggles what's that yeah you know it's
like if you were to say like like you're
doing it for like you're in a free
fantasy league so you're there's nothing
up for grabs you're just doing it for
shits and
giggles yeah no but say it and hit that
do the dance shits and giggles yeah
you're funny thanks buddy I appreciate
that what about are you an NBA guy what
do you mean do you like
basketball yeah are you a player guy
there or you a Laker guy Laker not a
Clippers fan me and LeBron have the same
birthday LeBron James he's the goat I
have a LeBron toy right there you're a
LeBron fan yeah he's my favorite
basketball player ever then why do you
have other guys CU I'm a Suns fan who's
number 32 off the Suns Kevin Johnson uh
that was Jason kid the year that he
domestically violenc his wife and we
traded
him yeah now he's Jesus Christ well when
he was with the sons he slapped he
slapped his wife and then we traded him
that's that literally happened that
number 32 is Jason kit yeah that's a
terrible tone of him if you actually
look at this toy just so people can see
what we're talking
about it's kind of racist like they just
were like this is Jason kid this is not
the way he looks like do you think that
looks like Jason kid like they at least
could have got the skin no I'm not the
face kind of like just like the no [__]
no that's not Jason kid dude look at
holy [__] why do you even have that such
a disgrace throw that away because you
know it's cool maybe now it's like oh I
have a fake Jason kid type of thing and
it's not your fault it's not like you
bought a fake Jason kid it's their fault
someone actually gave it to me and look
it won't even stand now it won't even
stand yeah J so Jason kid when he was on
the Suns he uh you him and his wife
wasn't his hair dyed yeah it was
bleached how' you know that I just seen
it before he had blonde hair he looked
like [__]
Eminem yeah Jason kid in Phoenix had
bleached hair and was [__] smacking
up his wife God bless her and now who'
we trade him to we traded him to the the
nets for Stefon malberry yeah I know
stepan Marbury didn't he eat like
Vaseline or some [__] he did yes he did
I don't judge him though you know random
tidbits don't you yes I don't I don't
blame him though for eating vaselin no
let me tell you why it looks good no
because end the day it's like it's [__]
that we might do be like weird as [__]
but like nobody would know cuz it's like
our secret yeah I mean look I wouldn't
eat Vaseline on camera like it be if if
if if in private Stefon Marberry had
this thing where he like likeed to hit
the
Vaseline but he did it like on cam it
was like early viral moment um was it
like attention thing like for attention
so this I don't know I think he had just
had some mental issues towards the end
of his career then he ended up going to
China and having a legendary career
there they actually have statues of him
in Shanghai he's like the Jordan of
China thanks to 2K I know Stephon
Marberry I didn't know him before like
me I wouldn't I mean I'm 2005 baby I
mean was he even in the league in of
course yeah when did he retire from he
was drafted I think in 99 it was him and
uh Kevin Garnett they were on the timber
wol you like Kevin Garnett yeah kg was
was was sick for sure Kevin gett he's
like a good guy like like get drunk and
go like to the casino with and he start
cussing yeah
[__] hell yeah like that like
he'll motivate you like he'll motivate
you to run through a [__] War right
now yeah that's true I feel like kg
would be the guy who like uh should be a
coach but he's not you know understand
like kg I don't know why he's not
coaching right now but it's probably a
good thing he's not a
coach yeah he probably would get
canceled maybe huh screaming at people
cussing at them yeah yeah he's a wild
man shout out to kg nice guy I've met
him a couple times uh shout out to K
we're going on some tidbits here and I'm
I'm very impressed by your random
bleached hair eating Vaseline tidbits
that you know about random old school
players you are a real sons fan aren't
you yes you have a son's hat and I have
Devon Booker on my shirt what does have
to do with butterflies though it's just
a there's a brand called um the [__] is
this brand called felt oh is that like
free free promo no no no no no no I
bought this hat so felt they do they did
a bunch of new era collabs and the
things of these butterfly so it's like a
son's are you like a mandatory cap guy
like when you walk out the house you
know some guys like mandatory caps I
think I'll get to that point when I turn
like your age mandatory cap how old are
you 36 you're not that old no I could be
your father I have 18-year-old son for
sure yeah my kid's a senior in high
school just like you that's kind of dope
isn't it yeah so were you born in what
05 I'm tripping dog [__] no you're off
some [__] dog for real it's my own kid I
don't know his birthday yeah 05 what the
hell yeah cuz
[Music]
I what what's 2010 that's important to
my life yeah two 05 yeah you're right
obviously you're right you would know
when you're born